JOANNA SMITH: Learning
performance patterns
from the internet can make
it difficult to know what
content to bother listening to.
So here's the thought,
listen to your data.
My name is Joanna Smith.
And one of the most important
things that you can learn
is how to trust your tools
over someone else's rules.
Because talking about
performance on the internet
can often sound prescriptive.
Like, someone will run off and
write a huge benchmark that'll
measure this and that, and
this too, and oh yeah that.
But all of these findings
get boiled down to something
like, we switch
from relative layout
to linear layout
for performance.
And then people hear this,
and they internalize it
into a hard rule.
If I see a relative layout,
I should use a linear one
instead.
But blindly following
prescriptive performance advice
from bald guys on the
internet can be dangerous.
The fact is, any performance
advice may or may not
apply to your
particular situation.
For example, your
core users could
be on a different
device tier than what
the tests were run on.
Or the performance
problem might be
fixed in a later
release of the platform.
Or it might be a
performance problem,
but in your application
it's just not an issue.
This is why we like to
say, tools, not rules!
That is, before you run off
and implement some performance
patterns that you found
on the internet, make sure
that your tools are confirming
it's even a problem.
This is as simple as
running the performance
tools on your
application, and then
focusing your energy on
fixing the bottlenecks that
eat away at your frame rate.
For example, iterators
may be the slowest way
to traverse a list.
But if your tools
show that this is not
a perf problem for
your frame rate,
then there's no use changing
your existing iterator code.
However, it's always
a good idea to know
what could be a problem so
that when do run a tool,
you know what all of
that fancy data means.
Now, once you've made a routine
of relying on your tools
to validate what perf
problems to focus on,
the next big step
is figuring out
how to do this on
a regular basis.
Most people agree that
it is a smart idea
to run tons of unit tests
before checking in code,
or submitting new
builds to users.
These tests help to make
sure that your code is
generally stable.
So finding ways to create
unit tests for performance
will help you
identify areas where
your code may have dropped in
terms of user-facing quality.
To help you automate
this process,
there are some great tools, like
MonkeyRunner or the Espresso
Library.
Combine these with a
process fueled by data, not
prescriptions, and you can
identify the perf problems
in your app.
Now, if you want to
fix those problems,
check out the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns
Content.
Or take a look at our G+
community for questions
and advice.
But keep calm,
profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]